rise of iron has everything you'd expect
from a new destiny expansion we got a
whole new suite of brand new weapons we
have multiplayer with three new maps got
a new mode called supremacy got private
matchmaking we needed array I don't
think we could have shipped rise of iron
without a brand new raid tons of new
armor tons of new gear who is a story
campaign with characters and cinematics
new public events and patrols and nuke
secrets to uncover
rise of irons about looking at this
story that's existed in the Destiny
universe this character Lord Saladin I
am the lone century and my watch is
eternal it's this journey to understand
the past what happened to these great
heroes the iron Lords are gone but our
fight is far from over and through that
process you're saving humanity you're
becoming an iron lord you're so if
you're getting to wield a giant axe
the idea of playing through a blizzard
is something that we've never tried and
you're gonna see that in fell 20 feet
fell when our peak is very interesting
because we've never had the player
fighting through a social space before
you walk in there for the first time in
the fires lit and is just casting glow
upon to these eight heroes you've been
holding their weapons for two years when
we can take those elements of destiny
and put them all together into one
coherent moment I think it's awesome it
it's time to finish what I began so very
long ago come guardian help me give my
friends a rest they deserve this is the
Guardians journey with Saladin he's
sending you out into kind of a land
that's been forgotten in the Cosmodrome
you're going into Earth but it's changes
actually expanded you'll see the plague
lands post-apocalyptic sky there's lava
welling up from the ground we know the
devil's have been digging into the
Cosmodrome for years they've been
looking for something well what they
found is Siva it is nanotechnology that
can be used to shape things but they're
not trying to use it to build they're
trying to use it to destroy they've
started mutating their bodies turning
themselves into giant monsters
transforming the landscape even if the
Cosmodrome into this horrible burning
fortress world
hellz loose an old Russia every second
we stand here sivas influence spreads
and the devil splicers grow more
powerful keep fighting guardian
after the campaign finishes you have
patrols that really tell the story of
this continued infestation in the land
and we have a new strike that shows just
what the Fallen are doing with the ciba
it's a spooky place of the wretched I
there's this really neat boss encounter
a fallen captain has plucked and I I
don't know over fixed it to his weapon
he's using that to sort of tase you out
of your rat hole while this blind / just
walks around trying to crush you
we also have a few reprise strikes that
were bringing back for players
we very consciously set out to create a
journey this is Ark of claustrophobia
space inside the wall and then you get
on top of it and it's sort of this
amazing breath of fresh air you get this
Vista from the Cosmodrome it's lit on
fire and there's this death Sam boney
who's just trying to crush your bones to
dust
this giant machine with a ball arm
spikes on it
what does it mean in a raid when you've
got to run I actually want that tension
to exist there's something really
emotionally powerful about going in on a
journey reaching to the top of the
mountain and then crashing back down
confined once again
I think players had a lot of fun when
they played Court of Oryx on the
dread-nots and so we wanted to create a
similar type of experience in the
plaguelands give it this different theme
you ready for this almost Thunderdome
Mad Max kind of feel where you jump into
the ring the walls get closed off and
then it's just fall and start pouring
out here they come or you get a giant
flaming acts and just start beating the
crap out of guys
we thought how can we increase the ways
that you express the way you'd like to
play and what we came up with was
putting different talents on the
artifacts the artifacts are these relics
of the Fallen iron Lords so you'll quest
and burn one of those and then your last
step of that is taking that artifact to
the statue of the Fallen iron Lord fully
empowering that for you to use as a
player whether it's negating all the dot
damage in the crucible or whether it's
infinite sprint or turning fallen onto
your side
which is really really cool by the way
the artifacts that tyra offers change
every week so there are always be
something new and exciting for players
following the campaign
and you put snow everyone thinks of
pelts and cloaks and hoods wouldn't be a
knight's tale without a knight's armor
when you look at the iron Lords and you
look at the raid set look at the iron
banner set where you look at trials of
Osiris they're all new with a much wider
palette that players can pull from and
when you throw ordinance on top of all
that we're gonna see a lot more variety
in gear so the ornament system is this
really cool thing that lets you take
some of your favorite pieces of gear and
then you customize this weapon the way
you want it to be got your grade weapons
you got your iron banner we got new
exotics old exotics you like side arms
we got we got all the sidearm this time
around
callahorn upset
coming to the crucible and rise of iron
is a new game type called supremacy
defeat your enemy claim their crest it's
a fast-paced 6v6 game mode where every
kill you get Guardian drops a crest
picking up the crest gives you points
their glory goes to you guardian it's a
constant battle over picking up crests
and making sure that you're with your
team and not out of position if you pick
up an enemy crest you deny the enemy
those points excellence recovery we have
new maps we always have new maps there's
last exit lots of twists and turns
that's a really good close combat then
there's skyline a Clovis Bray
headquarters building on Mars it's a
symmetrical large map the last one is
floating gardens which is an open map
one thing we're really excited about in
rise of iron is the introduction of
private matches can't wait to see what
people r going to do then we will fire
up whatever match they want play with
their friends host tournaments have fun
our katie games they have to worry about
our matchmaking stuff that can do it all
themselves
sometimes when I play and I've
headphones on and I'm in that world I
get little chills because it's not just
the effects and the amazing graphics
it's the audio that helps reinforce the
journey that you're going through we
really want destiny to feel like it's a
natural world that you inhabit like it's
a world that could exist that does exist
the score is incredibly strong and the
work that the audio team has done on
this game it lights you up
it becomes something bigger than just a
mountain in just a fight becomes an
experience and you hopefully get lost in
that sense of fun that sense of
adventure that sense of the unknown I
want to see that translate to our fans
and our players when you see your
character at the end of the campaign I
really really hope that you feel
triumphant and proud like wow I'm
becoming an iron lord
you